welcome to this video playing a little
nail lien eel maybe something difficult
okay we have this is a Mexican black
white yep Michael yeah we gotta jump off
ski playing this line which is not super
exciting but quite solid let's see what
we get mmm playing Bishop g4 here I
think tend to forget that you keep it
simple yeah that's very simple actually
but okay not a not a problem or so yep
give me the Bishop Bishop edge for I
have g5 that's not such a great idea
okay no that's not going to be good
right let's be quick about that not
spent a jersey on on this okay so i can
click on g3 right what is the point is
that point let's take it okay so what
about g4 now isn't this good g-form okay
maybe Queenie one or some weird we move
like that maybe Queenie one takes 90 x
but ok it's not it's not a real problem
for me I can take it 97 that's not bad
it's not going for any of that okay so
night cheeks yeah no that's that's a
question I can just straight or I can
put it on c7 keeping keeping an
attacking keeping attacking idea so I'll
try that Queen edge for Queen age for I
think a lot castle that's okay it's not
going for that Queen edge for I couldn't
have castled I don't know but that was
it looked tricky I mean okay this this
is also very very unclear position but
and it looks good though trying to play
quick here not spend a long time and I
takes Queen takes for Queen edge to meet
okay seagoing queen edge for may be
right okay I can check if for now Queen
g4 and I grabbed g3 or I have 93 as well
or h5 age 5 h 5 is interesting as he
cannot take d 5 23 wins the bishop and i
have ideas like g4 or f5 it's totally
ignoring what i'm doing ok so i can take
here I don't get it absolutely don't get
it let's take it kicks on b7 I mean I
can also chadwick capture earth check ok
ok let's go there then
yeah whatever what a mess um hey I
should have taken you for stead of c3 I
don't know
one thing I have to be cautious about
the screen each Queen g3 check and not
King b7 due to Bishop a 6 ok we will
Queen you three I have to cover so let's
grab
ok on it c1 c1 is really a problem
because of roxy aid I'm just I'm just an
only understanding the implications
mm-hmm that's not good at all
I totally overlooked that idea how
stupid
see a jet how stupid is that I really
didn't see it I really didn't see that
coming takes takes rook cheeks can i
somehow counter check that night light
III it's not really working my team
couldn't be six is going to work check
things change Bishop takes Knight III I
also has Queen Queen the Queen e7 I
don't believe it i'm losing again like
11 game before the high school no
amazing
really amazing
and that's probably multiple ways to
kill me warily I really forgot about
books see it coming I was certainly
there was certainly something okay I
mean I'm not sure how good or anything
but something that could be played and
this I cannot play okay at least he's
taking some time even look eben or
something is probably good I thought
Queen d7 time clears rook c8 rook c8 is
a killer then
hmm maybe I can take a six next maybe
hmm
still going to be tricky any check on on
the diagonal that's still pretty bad
Queen edge for Queen a6 checking on g
326 rook c8 check still wins fam but he
hit seems he is kind of frozen here
fight forfeits due to disconnection oh
my god so I won this due to
disconnection maybe you are thinking
it's lost i don't think years now is
winning actually I was thinking queen
age Freud I didn't see him with them the
problem is if I take Queen g3 is killing
yeah this is chang key point so I don't
know I'm just busted really just busted
and he had a maid at some point here
there's check made Queen d7 now is this
a forced mate haha that sets now that's
very inhuman quit d7 what a move
threatening to check on CH and mate
great so what did I screw it up I really
think that that cannot be any good here
to be honest this this check had
computer says I'm worse so I really have
to take him Queen e71 irritated me here
of course Jack I was very much irritated
by this moves on and an f7 with check
and everything but it's no problem right
jack yeah okay let's set sets a double
attack and queen dee why I get that one
but I was really afraid of this back
here chanakya computers just doing this
and since I'm a poner basically or how
many points i'm out one porn just let's
just check and yeah I'm p.m. lost really
yeah and this is the force made I didn't
see a move here simply I didn't see you
move then this is a bit better but it's
still not great channel at this check
check I'm probably losing the e poorness
is stopped that was lucky it's still not
the high school still out the high
school I mean I think me check this what
is the high score 2 512 so I'm two
points two points shy of that okay um
that's good next game would be
interesting thanks for watching